in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Nathan
and Michelle are with us hey how are
y'all
hi Dave welcome welcome where are you
from Indianapolis Indiana fun and here
in Nashville to do your debt-free scream
yes sir
love it how much have you paid off we
paid off a hundred and nine thousand
seven hundred and twenty dollars I love
it way to go and how long did that take
17 long months area making walk on the
income during that time between 118 and
120 mm great what do you guys do for a
living well I was in sales and now I'm a
stay-at-home Papa with our two little
ones oh wow
and my wife is a pharmacist for the VA
oh very cool
good for you gosh well done what kind of
debt I'm guessing pharmacy school 110
thousand nope that would be me
oh you we actually right before
financial peace we went out and bought a
nice new Range Rover and then we had
credit card debt and then actually my
student loan debt had been around for a
long time
Wow okay so Michelle you didn't have me
dead you just got this guy right yes I
got the guy Wow so did you keep the
Range Rover or pay it off no we couldn't
stand the sight of it after about four
weeks of financial peace oh we got rid
of it okay what did it sell for
thirty-seven thousand and that was part
of the 110 then part of it yes and we
paid a stupid tax on that of about three
thousand dollars to get rid of it of
course that goes with the territory yeah
very cool so now everything's paid for
how's it feel feels wonderful yeah so
Michelle tell me how this all started 17
months ago what happened
well we actually were invited financial
piece by my parents there was a the
church they attend there in Indianapolis
offered the course and my mom just
nonchalantly said when you and Nathan be
interested in attending so we thought oh
sure well we'll go we'll attend at the
time it was kind of just to find out
information we thought we could get some
investment advice that type of thing and
I think it was very owing to realize by
the second week how much doubt you
really
had to add it all up and realize we were
over $300,000 in debt and it was normal
most people with your mortgage your
car's school loans it was just kind of
amazing and then after that second one
she had that big aha moment then yes the
aha moment and then suddenly we just the
whole perspective changed we decided we
just really were listening to the
program and we really felt as a steward
of God's money and being able to do what
was right so we just really got inspired
and Nathan really let our family you
know to really be good stewards of God's
money Nathan do you remember what it was
in any of the lessons or one of the
things that was said that caused that
switch to flip so violently because you
guys just I mean you went from going
them 90 miles an hour one way stop got
off the exit went 90 miles an hour the
other way yeah I did probably week three
in financial peace where I think you
started breaking down how much this debt
really cost you over amount of time and
like my wife said we just got ahold of
our heart and we wanted to be givers
instead of just takers and so we just we
really just did a 180 and just one day I
was just like oh my gosh we got to get
rid of this car and so we actually went
down to one car we still are on one car
oh my gosh yeah so Wow
and we we did a complete 180 so well
with no payments at all in this great
income it won't be hard to save up and
get you a card I mean it'll be a big
deal Wow well congratulations you guys
so what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt I mean you paid off
a hundred and ten thousand dollars in 17
months what's the key now losing focus I
mean first of all husband and wife if
you got a great partner you guys on the
same page that's huge that's that's half
the battle and staying focused on the
goal keeping your intensity up because
we actually let a financial peace class
in our church and one thing that we
notice is that over time a lot of people
you know they're real excited the first
in you know nine weeks after they finish
and in the first couple of months after
that and after they sometimes they just
kind of burn out and you really have to
keep your intensity up and remind
yourselves every month what you're doing
what you're what
actually doing this for so I'm just
keeping the intensity up and keeping
your focus changes everything
yes well way to go you guys absolutely
awesome congratulations and thanks for
making the trip down all the way from
Indianapolis to do your debt-free scream
right here in the lobby that's a lot of
fun all right Nathan and Michelle a
hundred and ten thousand dollars paid
off in 17 months making 118 to 122
including the sale of a $37,000 Range
Rover count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream okay one
two three
that is so fun
you